what's the craziest heckler story you've
ever had and i'm not talking just like
you know some banter back and forth i'm
talking about like got pissed rushed the
stage etc um i've never heard that asked
on here before and i just wanted to know
thanks guys love you both
cheers brother thank you
that's a classic
that's a good one you got one well i've
had so many bad heckles uh but the one
that really [ __ ] me up was
i was doing a i was kind of new i was
probably like three four years in i got
a college gig which was huge yeah good
money fly you down put you up
and i was in florida and it was called
florida atlantic it was an all-black
school which i didn't know but i don't
give a [ __ ] yeah so i show up and i had
to follow a rap group it was like kind
of a talent night
i had to follow a rap group and they
were like
twirling shirts going kill whitey you
[ __ ] the cops i'll kill you you know
[ __ ] this [ __ ] or whatever and they're
killing like the whole place is jumping
yeah yeah it was the dnc basically yeah
yeah
yeah and uh i remember there was like a
little cute nerdy black girl with a
clipboard going okay you're next and i
just want to let you know it's very
diverse like it's not diverse it's all
black i'm a diversity
but whatever so it was me and this other
kid and we were both supposed to do 30
minutes
so uh you know these people don't want
30 minutes of one guy so he goes up
first and they trash him immediately and
he gets off after like a minute and a
half and i was like what are you crazy
you got to do your time at least so he's
like [ __ ] this i'm out of here i'm
calling my agent he was like a
he had self-esteem this guy oh yeah yeah
yeah so then i'm like all right and then
they bring me up like oh we got another
live one coming up oh baby and then he's
looking at me like oh this guy's a goner
like i totally set up for failure so i
walk on stage and i'm walking to the mic
the mic is like right where that camera
is and i haven't gotten there yet and
some guy goes look at this [ __ ]
kills kills
a huge laugh so i was like all right all
right i can handle this so i was in such
a new york state of mind i was like damn
man what if i was actually gay and he
goes no no you are
that got an applause break he's getting
high five they're crowd surfing this guy
he's a hero and then i try to do 20
minutes uh on uber after that and they'd
i just ate my lunch for half an hour but
i did my time
yes yeah but it was brutal man that was
i was just watching my watch tick
long half hour long 30.
like the irishman why do you think oh
the irishman's unbelievably bad it's so
long doesn't even make any [ __ ] that
or the departed whatever i don't know
the difference between the two the
[ __ ] shit's horrible you know what
i'm saying dude yeah some of it's so
[ __ ] bad um i would rather watch that
guy sheamus from wwe wrestle that seems
more authentic
to the irish mafia
um
but dude why is it that comedians can
take that [ __ ] and what that thing
because that's for some people that
would kill them that would put them into
a mental breakdown that's true i think
because we have our me our mind is
already so mean to us so we're like oh i
can handle this and they were kind of
laughing so in a weird way i was like
they're trashing me i'm the punching bag
but at least i'm creating entertainment
even though i am the butt of the joke
we're all having a good time i mean i'm
not but they are right so there's a part
of me like all right at least this is
kind of
fun for them but it was it was harsh
yeah even though i'm the butt of the
joke at least they're having a good time
yeah like if i wasn't there they
wouldn't be laughing right and it's
they're mocking me and it hurt but at
least i'm a part of something
yeah so i i took it
yeah man i uh i have one like that
university of north florida they booed
us off this they booed me off the stage
they didn't know i had to come back out
in florida yeah they didn't know i had
to come back out between each it was a
battle of the bands
oh yeah they didn't know how to come
back out again between each band i
burned all my i was supposed to do five
minutes between each band right i told
him i had 40 minutes i had [ __ ] 18
minutes
i burned it all out the first time and i
had to come back out [ __ ] like six
more times oh my god you just gotta
start riffing what is that a clock over
there holy hell oh it became a running
gag when i ran at least about the third
time the fourth time it was like no way
this dude's back
i actually physically became the joke
there was one time and they used to have
this room in la called um
[Music]
it was like at a bar cafe in ucla and
westwood
it was like uh college kids are ruthless
yeah and it was ucla bart so there's no
chick it's a it's a sad
environment
like compared to what college most
college kids are used to yeah
so
one kid starts tackling me in the
audience dude he's talking [ __ ] right i
got just lost it man i get off stage
i'm coming at the dude start choking him
what yeah choking the guy wow and i
really had the mic in my hand the whole
time i'm choking him right yeah ah you
could hear the swallowing oh yeah you
can hear it all it's crazy and i'm like
why were you being so mean to me just
the [ __ ] lamest thing you could say
to somebody yeah
but that was that and people were dying
laughing because he and i are tussling
but the mic is right there good for you
but i had one similar hartford funny
bone this is years ago there's probably
like
25 people in the room i'm eating my ass
this guy is in the front row i'm talking
a real nerd guy like a fat guy with
glasses and a beard and he had
a woman with him
and another like a sister and his cousin
or something and he's just this guy is
like a loser and i'm bombing and they
keep doing the thing where they mimic my
bomb like i'd be like uh mick ultra huh
that's the punch i need to go mick ultra
that was bad and then i'd be like well
what about a shag carpet he's like
carpet nothing there you know and it was
no one could hear it but me so he was
like taunting me so i just lost it on
this guy and i was like [ __ ] you you
piece of [ __ ] and apparently he was like
kind of downsy or something so maybe he
was not [ __ ] with me maybe he was
just
being [ __ ] or something and i but i
didn't know that i kept going at him and
this is when it gets really bad when
you're like [ __ ] you and i just got
angry it wasn't even funny and this guy
in the back goes go easy on him so i go
well [ __ ] you too what the hell i'm up
here alone blah blah blah
so eventually the guy
got up the the [ __ ] guy got up was
like what the [ __ ] i was like oh [ __ ]
this guy's all you know a little little
melted and i was like oh [ __ ] uh all
right well what are you gonna do and
they threw the kid out and they had to
throw him out and like he was like kind
of moaning and stuff oh it was bad
and then i had i had like another 20 to
do after that it was a nightmare so now
the other crowd hates me because i
i [ __ ] on them it was going to hell man
yeah i didn't know i didn't know you
didn't know and that look i had the same
thing happen man um that's a very good
story and it's better than mine but i'm
still gonna tell mine please i'm in san
francisco and it's at like a weed
conference or something right and i
don't even smoke weed so i'm at the
place people are blowing weed smoke in
the air and stuff and so i started
getting just zooted out on stage bro
there's a guy dressed it's like the san
francisco weed conference or just some
some
it was bad yeah um pre-legal or
legalized it's pre-legal okay so we were
still a big deal there were like booths
there was like thc stuff but it was
still they were pushing the limits right
and some guy was dressed like a captain
like a total captain and brings me on
stage at that point i am so cooked out
of my gizzard like the whole people have
been blowing joints it's the i'm the
last act of the day it's been an all-day
affair uh-huh there's probably 13 people
in a room that would seat maybe 150. oh
boy all these folding chairs
the guy in the front is mentally
disabled right nobody tells me yeah
nobody tells me i get up there i didn't
i literally didn't even know what's
going on i didn't know that i was a
comedian i didn't know what was
happening oh you were that high i don't
know if i was an auctioneer i didn't
know what was happening
it was not good right and this guy
starts saying stuff messing with me
and um
finally somebody yells out could have
even been you yells out that guy's
[ __ ] right
and i was like well put a sign on him
then you know right that's a good line
and then finally
it was the first laughs
[Music]
and i quit i got down i was like i'm
done i think it had literally been four
minutes dude
but when you're high four minutes is
like a week i think everybody the guy
there was like man you did great dude
you did great you paid me my money
all right yeah they paid me a thousand
bucks oh
that's big
that was big not a bad gig just trash
this uh downsy kid and get a check
could be worse
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one